play nice you have a girlfriend line
does that not help you do makeup
oh no she like makes you go to the
foreign [ __ ] if I do I sit in the
boyfriend chair there's they usually a
chair there where I sit down well I
watch a lot of YouTube videos about
makeup so I might have an upper hand
like I know the difference between
eyeliner and mascara well you think I
know a lot because I'm married but I
really don't know much about makeup very
marry prism eyeshadow by L which a lot
of youtubers talk about this brand these
are very unusual colors
yeah it's dispersing nicely I don't it
looks really pretty but I'd like to see
it in a few hours
that color payoffs not that high based
on the NED Fulmer electronics test if
it's heavy it's expensive then this is
cheap so I'm gonna go $13 1301 $45 30
but maybe you could tell me that this is
five dollars I'd be like yep that sounds
right and you could tell me that it's 60
dollars I'd be like that sucks but
sounds right pretty good [ __ ] ten
dollars
oh that makes me happy I'm telling you
it's all about the payoff it wasn't
there
NARS sounds like your burnout friend
from college who like had the fake ID
wears a beanie for no reason the middle
of summer
NARS is pretty expensive like I feel
like if you have like a whole thing of
NARS you're like you're doing okay in
life this isn't skintone for sure that
looks like a [ __ ] carat so it's a
good observation Ryan this is not
skintone
the other one had six colors and it was
ten dollars this one has two colors that
should be six divided by two so this is
three dollars and 33 cents I'm gonna say
45 on that one - I'm gonna say 35 I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna say $12.99 35
bucks
I'm gonna go $15 no no no
NARS NARS oh that's cause he's secretly
a drag queen ma I wish I'm like not
happy to be closer like that sucks
make it opens okay I feel like girls
love urban decay they were talking about
decay so good urban decay that is an
expensive sounding brand the package is
so wonderful there's a color called
sidecar just search your mind what do
you think that looks like this comes
with a brush but I know that's expensive
it is double-sided which is cool this is
like the Darth Maul with makeup brushes
I'm gonna feeling I'm doing a bad job I
don't know I think I'm positive this is
a great color these are beautiful
can I have this okay this is probably at
least $45.00 $49.99 I'm gonna say 80
bucks I'm gonna say 45 $55 I'm gonna go
$80 and I'm also keeping it because a
good deal can edit it bit
oh it's guys SPF 23 in it oh that's
always a good to born this is gonna go
either way because I feel like this
could be like super cheap or it could be
like what is weird is makeup cuz it
feels like lotion if this is like
alcohol plastic bottle always cheap oh I
ruined it how do you not get makeup on
your makeup I'm gonna say that's gonna
that's gonna cost $45 it is covered in
French $17.99 $35 I feel like it's 20 if
this tiny thing cost 20 bucks that's
crazy
no no that's the good [ __ ] right there's
an Xbox why so Ned's overreaction aside
this is [ __ ] insane I'm sad I feel
like I've just been led into a big
secret where I didn't wrong
feel like I just walked in on my parents
having sex